there isn't any that's actually said
anything intelligent about energy in my
view and I and I will obviously take
that into account when we vote but they
haven't had to it's absolutely stunning
to think how little time energy actually
gets from anyone on the Democratic side
are saying alternative energy on the
Republican side there's not much being
set at all alternative energy as i
mentioned fabulous for 40 years whatever
that is in their minds by the way I
don't even know what it means because
it's a black box right now it has been
for the last four years in Congress as
well is that they've got to tell us what
alternative energy they're talking about
if it's corn based ethanol I vote no if
it's some other form of biofuel that we
can prove up over time and make into a
commercial scale great but don't tell me
you can spend unlimited amounts of money
and don't tell me you're actually going
to stop all the gasoline from being
burned in this country while you're
trying to create that future so I think
we've got to get these guys much to
become much more articulate about energy
for one before the elections totally
understandable in the nomination phase
so we have yet to write the script if
you will for each of these stand on each
of these candidates stand on energy and
the reason for that is because other
things have been able to take precedence
over it everybody's focused on global
warming and that's something that
everybody wants to talk about as you
know McCain's engaged in doing some
cap-and-trade legislation on the Senate
and others want to do the same thing
eps absolutely and by the way our energy
policy has largely for my lifetime
consisted of aircraft carriers in the
Middle East that's our energy policy
it's an embarrassment that the most
again energy consuming country in the
world debates the issue of energy so
seldom and does it so shallowly our
energy policy is determined by
nanoseconds around gasoline prices so if
Hurricane Katrina hits in 2005 we put on
energy policy act of 2005 when gasoline
prices retreat the next year we start
reversing the very same act then we go
back to gasoline prices are up again so
we want to do something more so all it
is is about appeasing you and I as
citizens that are actually doing
something when in fact they're doing
very little for the future of our
children
you